Oh someone on something right now we
plug that thing you guys can't see me
but I could see you we could see each
other
are we back walking down Oh
oh my god hello and welcome to another
box shredding edition of what's in the
box man I'm Jake Elwood and we blues
brothers man our gonna make these boxes
black and blue with this here knife oh
that's you know ie the knife the good
folks and Spin Master sent us more
things to open so we're gonna keep
opening them we got a show as long as
people send us boxes and spin masters
like here you go so what we're gonna do
is open these Oh show you what's in the
box as per the title yeah is the titular
name of the show maybe play a little bit
play have a good time then what happens
is Jason Mewes is gonna take this [ __ ]
good [ __ ] don't get me wrong but there's
voluminous amounts of it equal [ __ ]
could take all this good [ __ ] he's gonna
take it back to Jim uses what do you
call it
Mews cave it's gonna take it to the
Meuse cave where he is going to extreme
on his twitch channel and proceeded to
give these away to people who are
hanging out as twitch that's it kids
that's the rules of the game that this
is not challenging no this is not a
Netflix series you need to binge or
devote 12 hours - we're gonna stab and
then we're going to take their guts and
give them to you well he's gonna give
them to you but you got to go to his
twitch watch your twitch channel jmu JY
m e w es some people some people
probably watch him right now on JS yes
stream also on my youtube it on my
facebook but after we're done here
take take your own knife cut the cord of
this broadcast and then tie it on to J's
twitch stream where you can
win these fabulous prizes yay is that
simple alright man good folks of spin
masters gave us these boxes down so we
could sit around talking to each other
and look at you and hear the sound of my
own boys although I do love that yes yes
Lord gave us a knife good Lord gave us a
knife so that we could do [ __ ] with it
Oh what are you gonna do with the show
God what you'd alright we're starting
with this bad boy so I'm gonna start
down the seam here gentle well I'm
left-handed - see it's like real awkward
at my right hand don't miss and then
like [ __ ] hit me man that'd be bad
what's in the cab blood and guts put
this over here safely I want to put the
knife safely I mean these I thought
there was multiple things in here looks
like there is it's a whole box let's
take it out so they could see oh it's
heavy it's only two per case oh my lord
it's a giant box oh you are gonna love
this boy this is so you're not gonna
want to give this away this is up your
alley man it's mine is the giant
jumbling tower game 51 giant solid wood
blocks let's do it oh look at this cool
box - it looks like a suitcase or
something right from the good folks at
Cardinal established 1947 it's it's
literally kids a blocks of blocks does
it say
I got blocks on my head but don't call
me a blockhead blueblood dollars you
could play the game as instructed or it
is woods good enough to burn you know I
know it's summertime but like let's say
you run out of fuel it is this is a game
that's both fun and practical I guess
how do you play it and you could also
whittler whittling thank you
Oh [ __ ] you could whittle this into
any number of shapes of prison yeah
small totem of some sort man a keepsake
box if you just hollow it but more
importantly it's a game how is the game
Flav so he wheezed me
stacked I know you'd this for jank it's
a giant Jenga so it looks like you stack
them up and then you pull pieces slowly
out take it on the go it says this
actually could be fun the plate on here
but we'll see how time permits I think
him and I should play a game because it
stacks up to four feet right both P and
then we get to pull it and if tumbles on
someone hopefully it'll tumble right
we'll check that out a little bit right
on let's go for the next big box I like
that I like it
watch that knife always the most
dangerous part of the show ladies and
gentlemen
is when Jason does his only job which is
to use the knife but he did it
successfully no one was hurt oh the
knife comes back every once in a while
Batman has to do another hit just in
case so that's what you saw what do we
got here Oh
multiples man yeah a different
difference Oh Jumanji the game man kids
I don't know if you ever heard of this
Jumanji thing it was a old movie from
when we were kids I don't think
anybody's heard of it ever since Robin
Williams did it many years ago so I
asked somebody to explain to you what
Jumanji is not like it's in the pop
culture or anything like that this is
the game the og game man you don't get
to those rock movies with Jack Black
unless this happens a long time ago man
you don't get to see Kevin Hart do his
thing or Jack Black be a little woman I
said Jackie oh you did Danny a real of
life of reimagining of the original
motion pictures and book you know as a
book it was a book first and then they
turned it into a game and then a movie
um let me tell you man those Jumanji
movies made Bank oh yeah that's what
made a second okay I do have to say
right here I am a fan of the rocks and
he I feel like any movie he does yeah
exactly and he almost every movie who
wrote the movie print the rock and solid
muse what no way Jay
leave me and steal my shtick rock and no
no Jumanji yes good folks Cardinal
that's just one guy's only that's only
one game out of multiple games here we
pull each one out in just about octopus
octopus shootout I'd like to be under
the sea in an octave position boot out
load the marbles and get ready to play
spin to block shots and fire away love
it
score the most goals to win the day you
know what honey rhyme the directions it
makes it more fun and it makes me want
to play them best try me for plus my kid
can play this ready I'll do this you
lookin Josh no spin spinning spinning
block it's like it's like air hockey but
with octopuses very good and marbles I
could play this Logan
ages 4 and up you cool your daughters 5
years old this is in a sweet spot all
right there it is octopus shootout my
god there's a lot in here there's no
look at this this is timely as hell
have you seen trolls world tour the
movie that's sweeping streaming TV sets
crawls it's on home video and it made a
lot of money made like 100 million bucks
yeah so here's the game man trolls world
tour
trolls world tour game comes with a
fabric game gourd board character movers
musics 36 music friends tokens yeah I'll
keep going 40 music friends cards 13
part spinner one instruction cheese yeah
and then directions in French oh they're
cute man they look like little trolls a
fabric board so it feels nice it's not
like that
cardboard [ __ ] those board games give
you the look here come on in step on
felt we're classy or trolls world and
let me try something for you guys do it
that's her days your auntie sue he's
doing his french fry practices French
yes good thank you this
is clearly for kids but it says age five
enough so this is another another game I
could play with a little one right you
get to pick the next Oh next one is
called cops there's a bell oh there's
cups oh my goodness
match them match and stacks so there's a
bunch of different cups you flip and
look at the card you line up and stack
up your cuts cups in the
color-coordinated area and then you ring
the bell it's a color guard it says 20
so there's 24 picture cards 20 cups one
Bell and then the instructions and yeah
looks looks like you play with at least
four player order that's not a note
where you gonna cut at top see that Oh
see that tape I'll close my eyes please
don't cut there's little cups I need
cups man so you can play shots as well
it's a game for the whole family but if
you drink it's a game for a bunch of
people yeah that's kind of cool again
another fun game all these are a little
bit more kid-friendly than last week
from cardinal and Spin Master you could
play Doc Ock Green Goblin venom Sandman
Mysterio my personal favorite vulture
Kraven the hunter electro rhino or
lizard man grab the loot betray your
friends quote/unquote friends defeat
spider-man build your best squad love
six from ten of spider-man's most
sinister villains they give you like you
tend to choose from you pick six love it
all together to form the ultimate team
for a series of heists contribute your
evil services to pull off the heist or
betray the others by snatching loot
ahead of schedule
whoo so I like the aim is to betray
people and be shitty I like the front it
says is your spidey sense tingling
bring out your specialized knife oh
let's cut that and take a look inside
because my lord
Lord loves a marvel
I'll tell you that much look at that it
said well he's opening it has ten
sinister six villains each with six hand
sculpting cards to special action cards
28 high scars 28 spider cards 10
black-market tokens 32 black-market
cards 84 loot tokens 6 reference cards
one act of heist token and one
instruction manual the end guys there's
like little hand pieces ball pieces
purse and man and stuff mysterious no
that's what hand would that be for a
Mysterio no sir Sam man I see venom ruin
Kraven has his knife then we have then
there's dark Ock's tentacles his
testicles is using a cheat sheet guys
this is awesome I want to play the other
one seems the same to the other I feel
like the other games we did last week
same thing it was like deduce pretend
make-believe who's against you yeah we
were kids and they were just like push
the popper and go around the board
there's some levels going on in the [ __ ]
upwards speaking of levels can you rack
it into you jacket you turn racket into
jacket thank you and you read no can you
have a pig on the front you can you turn
racket into jacket you can with upwards
the easy scoring 3d word game so we all
know upwards man and if you don't
basically put down where it's kind of
like Scrabble but then you could build
on top it's kind of like the game I
guess you can't say Scrabble about while
comparing it to something else it's like
a letter tile game that you're very
familiar with but it's better because
they build on top of the words it's on
racket into jacket man I played this
game many times I could vouch
for how satisfying upwards is upwards is
a fun game you will have upwards of 10
hours of fun there you go alright we
have two more pieces we're gonna do that
pop who you rather these are this is my
game Pro explain this is like would you
rather eat 10 Muse poop sickles or would
you rather see Muse naked and and let
him bust chewy on top of your chest
would you rather a mummify your head
with toilet paper or B give yourself a
toilet paper diaper so it's little
challenges like that or hey would you
rather have baby sized feet or B baby
sized hands yeah that comes with 300
dilemma cards 100 prove it cards 60
scoring chips 12 voting tokens one card
tray and the instructions I love it so
they're saying if you're like no you
wanna think some of them you can prove
it yeah I'm doing and you actually get
to wrap yourself up a toilet paper and
stuff I'm sure you there hopefully they
include some black cards yeah so that
you could be like yeah would you rather
watch me masturbate I could play this on
this we could do this on stream and and
and play the game and do would you
rather oh this is a bag of dice it is
it's a bag of dice it's campaign dice 21
piece set for countless role-playing in
board games so you can use this with any
any any games including games that have
initials in their names like D oh so
it's just a box of dice man
and to end three satchels three pouches
if you will little pouches that have
rolling bones in them okay yeah yeah
that looks like Christmas
Christmas in a smart kid store yes
alright let's look at this next one man
pull out that knife Jason and let's
eviscerate this box
let's get inside the one it's it's cold
here on hops we're gonna have to climb
inside this giant Tong Tong oh this is a
box of all the same things and the same
thing is all right what do we got what
do we got bomb pop oh this is foul
headbands the quick question
game of what am i so you know it's the
you know that game where people take
cards they put them in their head they
remember they're playing it and
inglourious basterds yeah and he was
like I am I am King Kong you could also
do they have a phone one version of it
as well
yeah phone but this is the headbands one
man comes with a headband and it also
enhance your game but the headbands app
so you can so you put like you know to
Dolphin card on your head like this kid
on the best TV give them example and
then you say go ahead open it up you got
take the plastic off that one this is a
full box of these kids so remember when
this is all not very great here we could
put a mirror they could see them look at
that stack of goodness look at all these
fabulous prizes remember kids when weak
toys well done when we are done opening
these right here give Jason 10 minutes
he's gonna go to his house which is
ironically enough around the block we
live next to each other very close to
one another
to be fair I moved here first and then
he followed me but regardless we both
live in the same neighborhood and stuff
so Jason will get in his car carrying
all this nonsense and he'll drive over
to his house climb into his music a jump
on to his twitch stream and deliver like
some sort of virtual Santa these gifts
to lucky winners man they're insane
amuse me and I'll put a card in your
head there we go guys we're gonna give
you a little taste of headband Zach no
don't look at it I'm not I'm not don't
look at ya and then here's the timer see
it's which day okay I'm closing my eyes
don't touch your friends and alright so
look I will show you guys right here
what's in here hopefully it's saving the
timer all right now I don't have to play
this exactly so now I guess
[ __ ] start is it an animal No alright
is it is it is it is it sharp it can be
is it sexy I'm
if you're if you're into rich people I
guess
do you own one know who been in one is
it oh it's a plane am i a plane
you are not a plane but you're in the
neighborhood it's a yacht just listen
closely it might come to you a
helicopter we know when a chicken dinner
that was little wedding fun do it again
okay pull that out I'm gonna put this
one in
all right kids the secret word is
alright one more time alright hold on
we're gonna turn this again and go am i
human Know Who I am I do I have four
walls no but there's something around
you a big tube ooh can you sleep in me
[ __ ] yeah and I have many times oh it's
a bathtub no a pool can I go places in
it yeah you can travel far Oh a car no
bicycle motorcycle no those are I said
tube before huh - tube - top o rabble's
what Oh hovercraft
I mean sure but you know something a
little more within reach a plane well
you'll find out when you ask okay the
secret clue is all right is it an animal
it is oh okay yeah my pink I mean
you can be there is a drink named that
Oh drink - my parents used to drink all
the time
Oh green grasshoppers and they would
have this trip my mom frisky sex on the
beach know something
pink pink pink flamingo it's a bird
excellent guess it's not a bird it's a
plane it's not a plane you're that last
round now Ken about ask me can you fly
in the mall you are Oh what size animal
mine you're small okay am i a mouse
you're bigger than a mouse it's smaller
than a duck smaller than a duck
uh I'm a rabbit you are around the same
size of a rabbit but not as bushy or
fuzzy navel no all right
raccoon opossum smaller than both of
those but also something you might see
outside in a tree squirrel bands the
find of the day yes you two could play
my kid will love this game um and you
might be able to get it from Jay if you
follow him on his twitch channel when
we're done here all right we got it we
got one more knife and three more boxes
knife the [ __ ] out of that
[Music]
we have a package slip but we ignore
that
let's see man what the connor reads
5-minute dungeon battle together or
perish looks a little like work over a
cod a chaotic cooperative realtime card
game by connor read 5-minute dungeon the
most fun you can have in five minutes
well yeah i mean five minutes yeah I
might argue that ages 8 and up you and
your party of intrepid heroes are
trapped in a series of five deadly
dungeons to survive you must battle
together against dangerous monsters
obstacles and dungeon bosses to feed
each dungeon in five minutes or less and
you wins got cards got pieces I don't
sit here oh yeah I appreciate the
attention to the weird shaped box
yeah like a [ __ ] square you know what
I'm saying and [ __ ] rectangles look at
that these cats were like you know
what's gonna make us pop a box that's
shaped different and they're absolutely
right man five minute dungeon kids like
it alright let's see this little box
what's in this little box Guv'nor take
that knife and stab the [ __ ] out of that
kill it like it's Damien and those are
the daggers of Megiddo take the
Antichrist away so we have multiples to
hand out Oh ladies and gentlemen of
reverse charades raids where I would
have said sure us you know charades he's
right but how about reverse charades
here's the twist
everybody acts while only one person
guesses ooh
act out and guess more words than your
opponent's to win it's a fast-paced
party game where everybody gets in on
the act that's cool so instead of like
you know everyone gets in one person and
everyone's all waiting for the one
[ __ ] turn and [ __ ] everyone's playing
at once and only one person's guessing
like it contents
cards with a 60-second stand timer and
instructions man a hilarious twist on
charades all right so there it is are
you a rock band
yeah like here it is the card was the
air I'll whisper it well the card is
kickboxing shadowboxing nope
shadowboxing do I get to answer no
boxing traditional kickboxing yes doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo dee doo dee
doo dee together like friends because
friendship is magic wash your hands all
right now last but not least the good
folks at spin masters ladies and
gentlemen have sent this box is require
very careful opening do you like what
you're seeing here go to spin masters
website I guess if you want to buy thank
you to the spin masters folks for
sending us all this stuff and thank you
on behalf of all the people who will go
over to Jay's twitch channel later on at
where they'll walk away with some free
[ __ ] man we may be stuck inside ladies
and gentlemen but doesn't mean we can't
have a good time with all these toys and
even adults like games all plastic
sheets shall be removed before placing
the product on the shelves this is
beautiful this long I feel like I'm
gonna lift it up you're gonna do the
talking all right man Jason he is
pulling out what's called Hin fatale
Viking chess oh look at that turn it
around
that's pretty dope man so it is here's
the front of the box its net Nephite all
the fat Neph ah Tov Elna Fatih [ __ ]
Nevada
nepeta fella ah ha 'no Fatah fell Mufasa
fell there it is Nevada felt begins as a
Viking nightmare out man outmaneuvered
and on the verge of losing their king
you and your challenger must determine
the course will you live the Viking
nightmare and try to lead your king to
safety or will you play the attackers
and aim to overthrow the Kings table so
it
not exactly chests it's a whole
different thing he comes to the big ass
game board one King piece 12 Viking
pieces and 24 attackers so it's a very
beautiful guys it's heavy too heavy as
hell age is 8 not man but it's not
standard chess it's a fart not old
Neph are tough al the father felt chess
it's made up of weight what you say is
made up of lots of stuff whoo that's
pretty heavy man as Marty McFly would
say that's heavy man some of these games
you know you recognize but their
alternate versions is some of them are
like wow I've never seen this love it
and look at the king - he's a little bit
bigger hey I used to be a little bit
taller I used to be a baller mm-hmm this
is really nice it's got Stoppers on the
bottom so when not playing the game you
can cut it you could eat your meals on
it [ __ ] it's got multiple uses all
brought to you by the good folks at
marbles brain workshop out in Chicago
Illinois man
headless let's see if I can get it again
an awful enough an awful Novato fell
nevada fell watching chess fun to say
hard to say but rewarding when you get
it down and there it is yeah everything
that the good folks at Spin Master sent
us all those boxes we open them up well
we didn't open them up
one person did this gentle giant right
here man you see them with a knife
initially you get scared but sometimes
the villain is the hero ladies and
gentlemen so he'll never use that knife
to hurt you
it'll only used to help you and it'll
help you by opening up a box and showing
you what's inside that's them
helpful [ __ ] you want to help him follow
him over to his twitch channel and say
hey please sir can I have some mole and
he'll probably send your game look at
all these cool games just like that you
got a bull take something up in your
life some friend you don't really want
to shop for but you feel responsible get
him something all you got to do is go
follow Jay on his twitch channel man
it's that simple
if you're looking for me I'll be at that
Kevin Smith Club calm come visit me if
you like and stuff but for this time
being that's it we got nothing left to
open man thank you to some good folks at
Spin Master yes and the folks at
Cardinal the folks at those marbles all
these fine folks the folks who made all
these cool ass games and whatnot the
wood block game that's the move though
that's what we'll do when this is all
over oh yeah big Jenga yeah and Whittle
what is it called again wittle wittle
and I love it I was watching Vampire
Diaries and they said oh you don't add a
wittle and I was like wait what we
should do is get a knife widdle the wood
pieces into little knives so we could
[ __ ] protect ourselves from the
murder ordinance yeah as you can hear
you can hear them they're on their way
they're ready to murder and stuff but
you don't have to worry about that cuz
you're gonna be inside playing all these
fabulous games man thanks everybody for
hanging out with me and J for J and song
what do we call it chainsaw Bob's what's
in the box
I write that's want to do different
names are same now you've seen backstage
[Music]
for what's in the box
I've been Harold I've been Kumar well
done and what's in the box this week has
been a bunch of games you want to play
games we'll play games and I'm not note
all right let's try to get this before
they go I'm in wait what am I your
flower